[Music]
So, welcome. Uh, I I know a lot of
people might be familiar familiar with
you and especially all the amazing work
you've done at Google in the past and
with Sierra Sierra overall, but maybe
just give a one minute intro on what
Sierra is, who you serve, the scale of
it.
>> Yeah. Uh so Sierra in a nutshell we help
businesses build better more human
customer experiences with AI and uh
concretely what we're trying to do is
bridge this age-old gap between
businesses wanting to provide great care
customer service customer experience on
the one hand and the impossibility of
doing that on the other hand because of
cost. And I think we've all been there
just like being on hold. was like 000000
or uh I was walking into work a couple
weeks ago and there was a dude uh on a
call holding his iPhone with AirPods in
yelling representative representative
representative representative and um
like I'm not sure what circle of hell
involves you know waiting on hold and
and trying to get a problem solved but
I'm sure it's one and we're trying to uh
bridge that gap and so uh concretely you
know we're a year in change after launch
we have hundreds of customers we'll
serve hundreds of millions of consumers
this year Um, uh, we work with folks
like ADT, the largest home security
company in the country, built an AI for
them. If any of you have a SiriusXM
subscription, and contact them. You'll
speak with Harmony, an AI agent that we
built with and for them who picks up the
phone and can help you uh, get back up
and running, including sending a
satellite signal from space um, to to
get your radio up and running again. We
work with uh, one of the largest
mortgage originators in the country and
then a lot of uh, local tech companies
that you would have heard about. And so
um that's that's what we do in in a
nutshell. And um uh what excites us is
we think that every company in the
future is going to have an agent, its
own uh branded customerf facing agent
and we think it's what comes after the
website, what comes after the mobile app
and we want to help the the great
companies of the world build their own
and do it well.
>> So talking about AI architect, I would
say the killer use cases of AI are
coding and customer support today. um
the coding I would guess vibe coding and
some of these ideas are kind of t taking
hold
>> on the customer support side you know
Brett mentioned this idea of the AI
architect where instead of managing
software you're almost like the
personality coach and like really
thinking through what's the vibe that
the agent should have how does it
integrate so what is an AI architect
>> so around the emergence of the internet
and the web there was this role of web
master right and you don't really hear
web master thrown around a lot these
days, but it was someone who was
creating a company's in essence digital
storefront, right? If if they're a
business and thinking about not only the
technology, right? Uh uh are you
building an ASP or you have static pages
or or whatever in the dark ages of the
web. Uh but also it's like what does it
look like, what does it feel like and
and so on. So I think the AI architect I
would say is kind of the AI era and AI
agent version of the web master in a
way. And it's um it's actually Brett
shared on the podcast, it's a role that
uh we've seen emerge organically across
a set of our customers. And we heard it
first from one of our largest customers
where the the team of folks who are
responsible for managing, coaching,
improving, building their agent came to
calling themselves the AI architect. And
I think there are three parts to it. One
is you got to understand the the
technology, have a little bit of a feel
for what agents can do. And so doesn't
mean that you've, you know, pre-trained
a a trillion parameter model or uh even
been hands-on with a lang chain or um
even vibe coding, but having a feel for
the capabilities number one. Number two
is and a pattern we've seen we some
interesting things is a company's agent
needs to not only manifest the
functional capabilities of the company
but also be something of a brand
ambassador right what's the voice what
are the values what's the tone how do
you come across how do you create a
connection with the customer so there's
a real I would say aesthetic and taste
element to it how should it sound uh
does it have a persona right some of our
customers agents are the ex company
virtual agent
Uh, in contrast, we work with a company
called Chubbies. Uh, they make great
very short shorts, uh, that I am not
cool enough to wear. Um, their agent is
named Duncan Smothers and will tell kind
of irreverent broy jokes and so on and
speak in a a really funny tone. So,
making decisions about that and and many
other ways that the agent comes across
is the second part of it. And then
third, ultimately a business wants to in
engaging with its customers drive
business outcomes. So what business
outcomes are you driving towards? So
it's this three hats. It's technology,
it's experience and aesthetics and
design and it's business and I I think
it will be one of the fastest growing
job types in the next 5 years and from
what I've seen you know a front row seat
on this one of the most interesting as
well.
>> Where most of them already in the
customer support org or are some of
these people coming from more technical
teams and kind of like creating this
blend of a role? All of the above. But
the the area I've been most excited
about is seeing individuals in customer
experience teams and you know
engineering teams are often celebrated
and held up and so on. Your your CX team
less often. So uh but what's emerged are
people who really do have a feel for
what a great customer experience looks
like and are hands-on with the
technology enough and have a sense for
what the business is trying to do. So
the answer is folks emerge from all of
those teams. I would say the most common
and the one I'm most excited about are
the folks who have been close to the
customer in service support care
retailing settings and so on who uh kind
of put this badge on and and become the
the AI architect or one of the AI
architects for their for their business.
>> I'm sure there's a lot of people in the
audience that have been tasked to figure
out the AI strategy of their company,
whatever whatever that means.
>> The board says we need an really angry.
Um, so when you think about all the AI
architects that you work with, what are
like some of the traits of the most
successful one? Are they really curious?
Do they try a lot of products? Are they
very structured in how they evaluate?
Are they maybe more bite- based on how
they think about what tools to use?
>> I mean, there's a lot in what what has
made customers we've worked with
successful in developing an AI strategy
and actually applying it. I I think um
broadly across the businesses we work
with the most successful have not let
perfect be the enemy of the good. You
think about large language models and
agents these are probabilistic pieces of
software that could say or do anything
and so necessary in adopting them is
some amount of risk tolerance and being
willing to you know step into the pond
and and try things out. So a spirit of
exploration,
trying new things and taking some risk
uh is is number one. Number two is a
deep uh focus on actually solving
customer problems and real business
problems. I think uh too often there's
this hey let's apply some AI to that and
we'll have you know emerge from that our
AI strategy. No no no no like start with
a concrete valuable problem to solve and
it can be very narrow. Uh, you know, we
to give you a sense for like where we
and one of our customers started was
something as simple as processing a
single return. And like we celebrated
and they celebrated when their AI picked
up the phone and successfully drop
shipped someone a new pair of shoes and
printed and gave them a shipping label
to print, right? It is not, you know,
the pinnacle of complexity and so on,
but you start somewhere um and and learn
and grow from there. And then the last
thing I would say is
uh not shoehorning the way you've built
teams in the past or done things in the
past into the AI era. And so our most
successful uh customers and partners
have actually rearchitected their
customer experience and customer service
teams around supporting the AI agent in
being and doing better. So there's a set
of people for instance at one of our
customers who will review a couple
hundred conversations a day and
basically coach and refine the agent on
how to do it better, how to say it
better, how to make better decisions,
how to have greater empathy, how to have
better judgment. And that was not a team
that has existed, you know, anywhere
into the past. And so really thinking
from first principles and and not just
trying to translate naively the old to
the new would be a third element of it.
you know architect that's kind of like a
enter technical connotation in
enterprises like hey you're like the
software architect. What were some of
the build versus buy fallacies that
you've seen working with customers where
you maybe have the customer support team
that just wants something today and the
engineering team is like, "Oh, we can
just build this. It's just going to take
three times as long and cost twice as
much as buying."
>> The multiples are more than that, but
yes. Yeah. So, it's such an important
question and uh we get the oh, we're
going to build our own uh you know, why
should we work with you all the time?
And it's funny, we we have a slide, we
call it the agent iceberg, where I think
technical teams think, oh, awesome.
We're going to choose our language
model. Should we Langraph or Langchain,
take it off the shelf? Uh, you know,
what uh what embeddings model will we
use? Uh what vector database? And you
know, maybe we'll integrate some tools.
You know, we're we're done. And then you
put on your scuba tank and you kind of
you go under the surface of the ocean
like, oh my god, you know, there there
are hundreds of things from how do you
do regression testing and unit testing?
How do you do model migration and model
upgrades? Uh in voice, it gets just
shockingly complicated where how do you
separate primary from secondary speaker,
handle interruptions and a thousand
other things in the agent development
life cycle. And so um we we come to our
customers with uh what we call agent OS,
our platform for building agents. And
it's it's a very sophisticated toolkit
for incode building very sophisticated
customer-f facing agents. Now the the
architect right there's this whole other
side to building excellent customerf
facing agents which is the experiential
the the brand the market. So paired with
that we have a set of noode tools that
enable nontechnical users to build
refine coach edit update their agent and
importantly these two seamlessly
interoperate and and so I think when
folks approach us and say hey we're just
going to roll our own they look at oh my
goodness all of the things under the
surface of the iceberg the problems that
we have spent you know the better part
of two years uh running into and then
solving and pulling together in a very
coherent platform to build these scaled
customerf facing agents that can pick up
the chat, pick up the phone um and
handle a high degree of complexity and
the set of tools for non-technical users
to contribute uh to to the agent as
well. And that rings quite true and
where we have had um companies we've
interact with go down the path of build
your own. We've had many of them come
back nine months later and it's like hey
uh it was deeper and darker than we
expected under there you know can we
talk? So uh that's kind of the journey
and the the pattern that we see.
>> Yeah. What's the agent building
iteration process like when people are
building on Sierra or when you're seeing
people build agents like how should
people think about how to push the
envelope and you can also do things like
you couldn't AB test a customer support
person before now with Sierra you can
kind of have different personalities
like do you see people be very creative
with that
>> it's a couple levels one uh we've had to
essentially event invent a new software
development life cycle we call it the
agent development life cycle where you
have this non-deterministic piece of
software So, how do you test it? Well,
one of the things we've discovered is
the solution to most problems with AI is
more AI. And so, when you're testing a
company's agent, how do you do that? You
can't just put in a single input and
hope you get the the right output. We've
built a whole user simulation testing
harness where we can create dozens of
different personas with simulated
accounts uh even simulated devices that
they're troubleshooting and you know the
amber light is on or off and and so on.
And so first and foremost have had to
think through all of the parts of the
software development life cycle. Um,
with that as the foundation, you then
have this approach to building out every
every business's agent, which starts
with deeply understanding what they're
trying to do with their customers. What
are the key customer journeys? And then
we have a variety of techniques for
modeling those in code uh in a way that
is very expressive uh and lets the agent
simultaneously kind of hit the curve
balls and flex. If someone comes in on
one topic and goes to another, do that.
But then when it matters right be you
know down to fully deterministic where
needed like there's no hallucinating you
know compliance regula uh compliance
language that that you want.
>> From there uh we we then use uh the uh
simulations testing harness to in
essence have tens or hundreds of
thousands of conversations with the
agent before it's live for the first
time. And from there we can tell oh you
know it doesn't know enough about this
part or it needs to be able to handle
this corner case better and so on. And
then um it it really gets interesting
when we go live and we have a a set of
tools that give CX teams and engineering
teams deep insight into where does the
agent realize like oh like I'm I'm
beyond my abilities on this. I'm going
to hand off to to a person. Uh and then
we have this closed loop uh set of tools
where the agent can learn from its past
mistakes. It can be coached. It can be
improved and you end up with this kind
of upward spiral of performance and
capability.
>> Yeah. You mentioned beyond my ability.
What's your process for like staying up
to date on the ability of the models? I
think there's a lot of people that try a
model or try an app and it's like it
doesn't work but then it works a month
later because the models improve so
quickly. Uh what what's your process for
staying up to date on it?
>> Yeah.
>> Well, first of all, if you feel like
things are changing faster than they
ever have before, it's because they are.
Um I I I feel like whether it's I don't
know Dance Dance Revolution or Beat
Saber just like new models, new agent
frameworks, uh uh new benchmarks and so
on are just coming down the pike at at
an incredible and increasingly fast
rate. So I think one thing is I think
fairly typical I think we all do dipping
into Twitter acts uh reading the latest
research papers and and really trying to
just immerse oneself in things that are
even adjacent to what specifically
you're doing. So we don't yet use video
models but gosh what the you know V3
models are cap capable of and uh what's
emerging in like okay it gives it gives
you a hint of what's going to be around
the corner maybe in the area that that
you're directly uh working in and then I
just think there is no substitute for
hands-on and using it and so uh really
being handson with the tools whether or
not right again you're directly applying
them in in your work or what it is
you're
I think is so important and I I would
argue that uh understanding where things
are going is even more important than
understanding where things are today. So
the first derivative is more important
than kind of the absolute uh state of
capability. an example of a decision we
made early on was like we had a strong
sense when we started the company that
the uh cost per token was going to
plummet that model capabilities were
going to expand and and so you want to
be building to where the puck is going
as opposed to where it currently is and
and so almost having a ritual where on a
on a cadence you're checking in with the
capabilities of the model I keep in a
Google doc some problems that were too
hard right for GBT T4 to solve, but you
know 01 or 03 because can 03 mini do it?
Um and uh you're you're checking in on
the capabilities of these models to
basically plot again the slope so that
you can understand cool if we start
building this now this will intercept
you know at this period of time and we
could have this level of model
capability but with this latency and I
think that's that's how you build truly
great products that are at the frontier.
It's by anticipating the frontier.
>> Yep. Um I know we only got a minute and
a half left, but you spent 18 years at
Google. You kind of started the ARVR
projects. You started the lens project.
What What do you think about the next
interface for AI? So we had text, now we
have voice, obviously video coming. Do
you see the glasses are going to do you
think the glasses are going to work? Is
it more ambient agents? Like any
thoughts?
>> Yeah, I first of all, I think how we
interact with AI and agents is going to
look super different from today. Today
it's like mushed into what looks like
AOL instant messenger, right? A chat a
chat interface or it's a voice call. I
think agents are going to look like
shape shifters that can summon text,
voice, video, imagery, user interface,
and more. And you're going to interact
with uh every uh sense and mechanism
that that you have. As for the hardware,
uh look, I spent 10 years of my life uh
building uh in AR and VR. My strong view
is that uh glasses and wearables will be
the ultimate vehicle for the trusted
personal AI that is with you. Something
that can see what you see, hear what you
hear, uh that can whisper in your ear
or, you know, nudge you that way uh
visually. I I just think we're on this
path to every one of us having an
omniresent uh omniapable uh AI assistant
that can help us navigate the world uh
lead better and healthier lives uh be
smarter than we are on our own. And I
think, you know, going into your pocket
or purse or bag to retrieve the, you
know, rectangle of glass and metal and,
you know, swipe up and uh whatever it
is, I I just I think for such an
important capability that will feel in
time like an extension of ourselves, you
you want that to be with you throughout
the day. And so I think wearables, I
think glasses will be a a central part
of that. And uh it's something I'm I'm
super excited to see emerge.
>> Awesome. Thank you, Clay. Thank you so
much. Thank you. Thanks everyone.
[Music]